all right Giselle yes Giselle oh where
are you from where'd you grow up um I'm
from South Florida I grew up in Broward
County which is like a little north of
Miami
tell me about your family growing up
um so I mostly lived with my mom my
parents separated when I was like about
three I
um stayed at my mom's house most of the
time my dad wasn't in my life and
probably until like eight or ten and he
would like show up and then disappear
for a while
um so I mostly with my mom and she had
gotten married when I was like about
three to my stepdad and
um he turned out to be abusive he abused
like me my sister until I was about like
13 and no one found out about it until
around 15. what kind of reviews
um so he sexually and physically
physically abused me and my sister the
rest of the siblings was just physical
and sometimes like emotional too and mom
never found out
um she didn't but she was there the
whole time and I think as a kid like you
don't realize that you're like even if
your mom's sitting there you don't
realize that she's noticing it until
like I was older I realized that she was
there the whole time and she just didn't
do anything about it
did you feel like just like unsupported
by anyone any adult
um yeah when it came out like when I was
around 13 or 14
um
I had told my mom because my sister had
like kind of like a breakdown and she
ended up moving to my dad's house
because we thought it would be better
and my mom said that she just really
felt betrayed and like we weren't
supporting her and it was more about her
when we told her about everything and
she had used the excuse that he was on
drugs and he didn't know any better
because he was on drugs and he was an
alcoholic so how was he supposed to know
what was right or wrong was kind of her
excuse and we had ended up telling my
dad and
um my dad was going to go to court for
it like we did like videotapes and
everything like that for our stands and
my mom had to end up blackmailing him
out of it because my dad was into like
bad things and he was just all over the
place himself
so he ended up just like backing out of
it and nothing was ever said of it
to rough childhood for yeah and your
sister yeah and I don't think we
realized the impact it had until we were
adults like why you're going through it
you think that this is just life it's
survival this is normal this is how life
will be and when you get out into the
real world and you're exposed to
different cultures and different other
people's lives you realize what happened
you joined the military after school I
did I decided
um
so like around 17 I had moved into my
dad's as well and my dad had this thing
where he would go into hibernation and
we called it hibernation our whole lives
never thought anything of it and that's
where he slept in his room for like
weeks on end never came out and I had
lived at my dad's by myself at that time
and
um there was like there would be periods
of time where there's no food no toilet
paper and I would have to like go out to
other people and ask like family friends
or just extended family
and then one day I was just like really
depressed at school and they had one of
those stands for the military at lunch
and I was like you know what let me test
it out and I went and it was kind of
like not I want to do this for myself
but like it was kind of like out of
um
like kind of like out of hate like I
wanted to do something that was like big
and drastic because I felt like my whole
life I went under the radar and that was
like the moment that everyone in my life
started caring about me is when I joined
military and it was like that beginning
phase of going in
so I had did it out of spite and then
that's when everyone just became so
proud of me everyone was talking about
me wow giselle's gonna do such great
things she was always the star of the
show
so it was interesting to see how like I
did it out of hate and like as a way to
escape and it like kind of flipped the
script a little bit
for a little while
how old are you now I'm 22. 22. yeah
do you feel like that time in the
military how many years were you in I um
18 to I joined when I was 18 and so
probably like four or five years do you
feel like that
matured you changed you
um
it definitely wasn't healthy
um I had joined under the suppression
impression that it was going to free me
and in the beginning it was good like so
when you have like an abusive childhood
you're always under this control you
have no control in your life and I think
that's what the military replicated I
joined the military there was no control
in my life everything was said you do
this and you do it and you get paid you
spend it on this there was no freedom
and like in the beginning the first year
or two in the military you get like
confined to a space you're not allowed
to go off base you can't have free time
and there's certain people you can and
can't talk to so I think that was the
Rhythm I was in as like a kid and it was
like creating this parallel universe you
think there's some some something in you
subconsciously that was attracted to
that
um I think so it is very addicting to
give up control and just go with the
flow
because you don't have to make decisions
yourself you don't have to think about
anything you just do it
yeah it's interesting
and this was the Army Navy Navy yeah
and so you've been out for a little
while now I've been out for like
probably like three months and spend the
best three months of my life
you can you can start living now yes for
sure you seem happy and healthy now I I
am I am still a work in progress and I
still have like my really bad days and
dark days but I I often like I think
back to it it's just like such a
darkness and I see that like I'm not
clouded by that and I'm trying to
um I was like a big people pleaser and
in those environments it's easy to be a
people pleaser you get rewarded and like
when you're rewarded by people you're
abused by it seems like so much it like
so much incentive for it and I think now
I'm like leaning towards the other side
of the scale where I'm doing stuff for
myself and I'm being selfish in a good
way
uh drugs or other escapes were were
never part of your life or
um no I was so my stepdad was
um he was really into weed and
um alcohol and I was I was the product
of like being avoidant of it like I
hated people who smoked weed did weed
anything because I just thought
immediately like they're gonna abuse me
like they're gonna come after me they do
bad things and I think like even like my
sister she partakes in some of that
stuff like for recreation and I think
sometimes it scared me like I had like
this little bit of like
like why would my sister do that after
everything
but now I realize like I had to separate
those two like alcohol and like we don't
equal that I do partake in it but it's
not I've never been like addicted to it
or had an issue with it
and what's your relationship like now
with your family
um so I cut my mom off last year or the
year before that I can't remember
and it was hard it was like having
someone die
close to you but know that they just
chose not to like have a relationship
with you
and I think
um
like I had um been discharged for the
military for disability and I think that
I had reached my Rock Bottom in the
military and that's what like
prompted me to cut off my mom I had
given her the choice I was like hey Mom
like it's either me or him and like I
went on this big explanation and she was
like I'm sorry you feel that way that's
all she said she said if you don't want
to talk to me that's okay
and I had asked her I was like how do
you like lay in a bed with someone you
know who's touched your daughters beat
your kids like caused so much so many
like issues
and she was like
um she said that God has forgiven them
and that people change and you just have
to learn to forgive and move on
how do you feel about that
um
I have like a really
I have a lot of hatred for my mom and
like I often like tell my therapist this
like it's it's like
kind of messed up to say that like the
sexual and physical abuse doesn't
outweigh my mom choosing him over me
and like it's just really weird to think
that like someone who birthed you raised
you
and
like we just weren't enough for her to
choose
in your relationship with your dad
um
man that guy
it's a little on and off like my dad
disappears he has his bad days of
battling depression and drugs and
um he sometimes appears sometimes
doesn't
he calls me every so often like for
Father's Day I said Happy Father's Day
and he answered me like two weeks later
and was like well I love you and that's
just basically the epitome of a
relationship
yeah so you're 22 now what are you doing
for work
so right now I just nanny I nanny
because of my childhood actually I'm
trying to change that way if I'm that if
I'm out there taking care of a kid
that's one less kid in danger of being
taken care of someone that isn't so nice
maybe it's nice yeah and you're in
therapy I am I go twice a week and I do
a cognitive processing therapy to help
with my mental health but explain what
cognitive processing therapies so
basically you just like take your
thoughts for example like something
you're stuck on
um so like
like maybe a stuck point of mind would
be like
um
other people's thoughts outweigh my own
so I should just listen to them and you
just basically break it down and
um learn like the origin of it where'd
you learn it from and what bad habits
are like put onto it like are you mind
reading are you like twisting it are you
forgetting other parts of it and stuff
like that and you come out with a
thought that will help counteract it I
imagine at your young age
and what you've been through a big part
of your
challenge now is to
honor and respect your your own thoughts
yes and it's very hard
it's very hard when like you've been
suppressed especially like in the
military solidifying it as an adult
of like being suppressed and um
I think it's just hard because I always
second-guess myself am I right
are my opinions and feelings valid
what are your goals long term
so I hope to
um
I'm torn between two opposite Fields
microbiology and culinary
they're two different ones but I'm
almost done with my bachelor's and I'm
just waiting to move to start in-person
college that's great yeah so what do you
think
you know I've interviewed so many people
who have similar childhoods to yours but
they've taken a very different path
they've gone to drugs to escape they've
kind of
their lives have become unraveled yeah
terribly um
and you you kind of avoid that path and
you kind of kept your life together and
you're trying to build you know at 22
you're building for your future yeah
what what separated you from all these
other people that have fallen prey to
that kind of stuff
um
like as a kid
was
out of all my siblings the goodies
what they call a square I follow the
rules no matter what
and I think there was a point in time
where I like I do find release through
things that are probably not healthy for
me
but like being in the military
and
um like always being under scrutiny I
was more afraid of getting in trouble
than I my desire to escape it
was
and how's your sister's
okay my sister's doing okay yeah do you
guys talk about what you went through
with his kids and yeah sometimes we have
like our dark days and we like FaceTime
each other because we know like we're
the only ones who would understand and
like not judge because there's like some
thoughts that come with being like
sexually abused you like kind of doubt
yourself and like your thoughts go like
a way that naturally someone wouldn't
think of and you just go and you try to
like event about that to someone who
would understand it usually ends up in
us both crying and saying that it's okay
like we think the same way I don't mean
to
pry but uh can you explain what you mean
by that where your thoughts go
so
um for example like sometimes we'll like
have like sex dreams about
um our stepdad and it's like you
question yourself you sit there and when
you have those dreams you're like
because you have seen him naked so many
times you go back and you're like did I
enjoy it was I attracted to him do I
like it and you wake up and you're so
confused because you feel like this
confliction of like you feel like so
disgusted by yourself and you're like
also questioning everything that
happened like maybe it was me like maybe
I did partake in it and it wasn't abuse
and you just like start questioning
yourself and like you just need someone
there who isn't going to be like who
isn't going to pity you and like be like
oh I'm so sorry that that happened to
you just be like I understand you
yeah it's got to be a horrible thing for
a child to go through yeah and for you
it lasted a long time it did it was from
like three to twelve but I would say
like the worst years were probably like
around five to eight
I think like in the beginning it just
started off with like him putting his
hands in our pants and like I remember
this one time vividly we were all like
entering the house and it was like an
assembly line it was like me my sister
and then my mom he had just gotten home
from work and I remember me in like some
cartoon pajamas like the most kiddish
thing ever and like my stepdad took
turns saying hi to us sticking his hands
in our pants like groping us and then it
was on to the next one and my mom would
sit there and it kind of felt like she
was waiting for like this like
acceptance within herself that he was
happy with everything she was in the
room yeah she was she would like wait
for her turn because her turn was last
and so it was just interesting to think
that like she would just sit there
sometimes
she wasn't there during
um like
worse stuff but like we had like told
her afterwards and like she would just
go to him and hear his side of the story
and his side was the truth
yeah so that makes your your thoughts
your opinions like
and almost feel insignificant right yeah
and I think that's where like I turned
into a people pleaser because like if
everyone else is right then there's no
room for my own opinion so might as well
just not even say anything
I remember like this one time that like
it really solidified it of like my mom
choosing his side I was we had came back
from the beach and I was sitting on the
toilet and I ran out of toilet paper and
I opened the door in my sister's room
was right across from the bathroom and I
was like hey can I get some toilet paper
and I see my stepdad like rummaging
through her stuff she had like one of
those desks that had the shelves on it
and she had like a a board game on the
Shelf and he had placed a camera in it
but I was unaware he said he was
cleaning her room and he was high I
remember he was high and drunk and I was
probably like six and I was all aware of
my surroundings
and
um my sister was in the shower while I
was asking for toilet paper he got it
for me and then she had gotten out and
then by the time she had gone out gotten
dressed she heard a beeping in her room
and she was like Giselle come here mind
you I'm just six my sister's nine I
don't know what's going on and
um
she had called me into the room and she
said Giselle I found his phone in my
desk like recording so he was trying to
record her getting dressed after the
shower and I was like oh my god do you
have the video and she's like no I don't
I deleted it like I don't want I don't
want to see that and like I understand
that you see like a video that was taken
without your consent you're going to
delete it and so I was like I know who
will help I know who will help and I was
like Mommy will help mommy will help and
she goes no she won't she's out please
don't tell Mommy whatever you do I was
like don't worry she will help us and I
remember going to my mom and I was like
Mom I need to tell you something and I'm
like freaking out like six years old I
don't know what I'm doing I'm like Mom
he put a camera I remember seeing him I
was on the toilet and he was putting the
camera in there and she was like let me
talk to him and he was outside already
and she I go please don't talk to him
please just believe us and do something
I was like please don't talk to him she
went to talk to him
and it's awkward because she comes back
and she's like he said that he never did
that and if his phone got in there it
was by accident
so it accidentally sets itself up in a
board game and Records that's all an
accident and I was like thinking to
myself I was like okay but then you have
to deal with the fact that he knows you
know and you told your mom for help but
there was no help and you just have to
live with that afterwards
and I don't know that's just weird to me
yeah
yeah it's got to be so difficult for
a child and now an adult yeah because
those those experiences as a child
form how you process things as now yes
definitely it's got to be terrible it
creates like these what ifs like as an
adult what if I had pushed a little
harder what if I had call 9-1-1 what if
I had did this do you question yourself
a lot now I I did I try not to anymore
but
it just every scenario it's like you
could have done better you could have
done better but with what-ifs there are
repercussions to those what-ifs and like
in that moment I had to cope with the
fact that I was there to survive I I
really didn't have the choice I was it
was flight freeze or Fallen you're six
years old yeah and
so it's just really hard because like in
my adult mind I'm like
it's like the same mine I had then kind
of you're like the same person you're
like why didn't I say anything like when
the doctors ask are you hit at home do
people touch you and you're like no and
you think in your head don't say
anything because you'll get in trouble
even more but you don't realize that the
world's such a bigger place at such a
young age
would you go through emotionally now
um
um where I'm leading is that does does
some of the do some of those emotions
come from what you went through as a
child
they definitely do I really had a hard
time trusting people being physically
intimate with people I hate when people
touch me even if it's just for a hug
anything like that
um I'm definitely very insecure in my
own thoughts like coming here was also
like a big step for me like
what is my like
is my truth enough
it takes a lot of courage to do
something yeah to sit in that chair
doesn't it yeah it does you're doing
fine
and you have friends now I do have some
friends I have
um I have this one high school friend
and I have a a friend from like Middle
School I tend to keep like
those friends the most friends come in
and out of my life especially when like
I was I just got out of the military so
everyone's moving and stuff like that
everyone leaves and comes
but what kind of things do you worry
about now
um
I worry about
I would say
I think I struggle the most with like
being okay that I don't maybe have
parents that are like loving
and
um
like how that affects me like when I go
through big things and I need someone to
call who do I call type of thing like
where's my support system like I'll get
nowhere without that support you're
forced to grow up faster yeah
and like be more like you just have to
support yourself which is also hard when
you question everything you do so it's
that's one thing I worry about I also
worry about like
um
I guess like my other siblings like how
they're doing what they perceive of me
and my sister and like what will they do
with the information and how will that
change their life and whether they
believe me and my sister because if
everyone in the family goes with the
facade this is all of this information
common knowledge in your family now it
is common knowledge it is not addressed
at all everyone still has parties with
him brings little kids around him it's
not a big deal it's it's more like
Giselle and her sister were just like
they couldn't handle it and that's what
it it's come down to
what's your greatest strength
I think my greatest strength
is it's probably strength and a weakness
is playing things like being strong in
the moment like I can make you seem like
nothing ever happened to me and then
like it's good for that moment but then
I don't ever address that feeling I just
push it off I would never suspect you
went through something as horrific as
what you went through yeah I definitely
you seemed like perfectly adjusted I
definitely minimize and like just push
it down because if you don't let it to
the light you don't ever have to
acknowledge it yeah
and so what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
22 years
um
not to trust anyone to stand up for you
you if you want if you want to make a
change you have to do it yourself and
like even if I can't change that
scenario I can't change what happened in
the military I can change what happens
now and I could be there for myself
so in the military you went through
something similar I
I was
and I had brought it up to lead
and it was just dismissed they were like
we're going to give them another chance
because it's all hearsay but when is it
not hearsay if something happens it's
going to come from Word of Mouth
and
um I just had like a mental breakdown
and I think it was because it was like a
parallel universe
to my childhood me bringing up something
and no one believing me or giving them a
second chance and they're like it's okay
that he did it this one time
and
um I had ended up like having a really
bad panic attack and I was like
hospitalized and then that's when like
my journey of mental health started was
from there because I had never been seen
before that for anything
that's great yeah well I'm glad you're
doing well now yes
all right Giselle thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck with me thanks thank you so
much